holy cow my voice just got bigger
i could almost fill this room without
the amplifier but we won't we won't do
that
how's your show been so far
been having fun
i'm very aware that i am the only thing
between you and a beer
so
this is it before the party starts so
let's have a little fun uh my name is
richard campbell and uh i make i
carl wasn't able to make it to the show
this time and so we're not recording any
dotnet rocks and so i said hey i'm loose
and so they they made me do a bunch of
sessions this was not originally on the
agenda so let's can we do a space talk
before the party i'm like okay we do a
space dog i've written this talk a while
ago and i you may or may not know the
story but i've been making podcasts for
a long time and a few years ago my
friend carl franklin talked me into
making the geek out episodes it was
totally his idea i thought it was a bad
idea and i was wrong
and so if you go to the dot net rock's
website there's an option to filter by
geek out and there's about 80 of them
or you can go to the url geek out dot
show and it'll give you this list
of these geek code episodes and this is
all the geeky stuff that i like and we i
usually have a voting system like which
one should we work on next really what
the geek out for me is is me finishing
some thinking organizing ideas and so
forth to talk about a given subject and
i've had some interesting experiences
because of that one of which was
a moon-based talk which if you've been
to other ndcs i've done it a couple of
times the original moon based podcast i
did was actually based on a european
space agency paper about what it would
take to establish a base on the south
pole of the moon very much like
antarctica it would be occasionally
inhabited and the kind of science they
wanted to do down there and i thought
that was all very cool so i did this
moon based geek out uh that came out in
in 2017
and then that summer nasa called
which is a good day
i mean let's be honest the first couple
of emails from nasa i'm like that's not
nasa
and you eventually look at i'm like oh
they're pretty persistent so i get chuck
on the phone and chuck's like oh we
really like your podcast well that's
nice thanks that's cool it's like hey
have you uh would you be interested in
doing a presentation on it
yeah okay
to who well to us nasa
yeah
it's your stuff
like yeah we like the way you tell it
like okay so i got to go to the nasa
ames facility
and my mother's pretty proud it's
something to drive into a nas facility
that's your face on the front of it so
that was that was a pretty good day and
since then i've been asked to do a
variety of space talks and so i get to
keep working on this material i mean i'm
interested in everything that's going on
in space anyway but
folks like the way i tell it okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna keep telling it this is
a new one this is one i've just worked
up this year based on sort of the latest
things and i break it down into
in a one-hour summary because i could do
several hours
believe me
ah you may know
uh in a one-hour summary let's talk
about three areas the current state of
lift so how are we improving our rockets
what have we got going on right now
uh the space station and what's coming
for the space station in the next few
years
and then uh what's happening on the moon
so that there's a push to get towards
the moon and that's ongoing so those are
going to be sort of three topic areas
and i do want to address the sort of
rush of billionaires
so this summer was a little bit weird
you know richard branson finally after
many years and some fatalities
in july
took a ride on spaceship 2. this was a
vehicle originally developed by bert
rutan with paul allen's funding paul
allen one of the old microsoft guys who
retired many many years before and ran a
company called vulcan and
habitually collected world war ii
memorabilia of course when i say
memorabilia i mean tanks
and aircraft at one point he had like
the fourth largest air force in the
world
he's one of my you know i've always
thought i'd make a website called you
know tech billionaire or super villain
that figured out who's the closest to be
a super villain because he's the guy who
has like not only that he has the giant
ship but his giant ship has a submarine
and that submarine
has another submarine
and he was collecting uh photographs of
the japanese uh battleships he found
yamato he found musashi like that's the
kind of thing paul allen's into and so
yeah he built a spaceship on the side
and then richard branson commercialized
it into this this thing called virgin
galactic and it's a sub-orbital vehicle
they use an aircraft to lift this small
spacecraft
up into about forty thousand feet or so
at fifteen thousand meters then the the
vehicle drops off fires a very
interesting rocket engine a combination
solid gaseous engine which is unique if
you're into rocket engines which then
goes up to roughly 100 kilometers ish
considered above the karman line so
nominally you're an astronaut you get a
three or four minutes of free fall as it
peaks and begins to descend down so now
you can float around and do that fun
stuff and then after a few minutes you
need to get back in your seat where it
begins to spiral down
and actually land it doesn't really have
a reentry process per se because it's
never going fast enough to really have
any atmospheric heating or any of those
problems but it does get not high enough
above the atmosphere that control
surfaces don't work properly and so
rutan's great innovation in this vehicle
was this thing called the shuttlecock
that the back wings the the elevator
section actually pivots upward to force
the hull into a stable position on the
way in through re-entry
it's a clever design
but it's not ever going to be a
significant vehicle in space flight
you're not going to go to space station
on this there's some experiments
they are talking about selling seats on
this or somewhere between three and four
hundred thousand dollars u.s
if you ask me
save your money if you'd like to do a
little free fall you can go on an
aircraft ride that flies parabolic
curves for about three grand and get the
same nauseating free fall effects for a
lot less money
so
this
this is a billionaire's toy all right if
you want to have fun if you think
spending 300 grand or something is just
not that big a deal it's like well i'm
tired of crashing ferraris what can i do
today
this is one of your options
he's not the only billionaire that had
some action this year jeff bezos who has
been spending apparently a billion
dollars in an amazon stock for the past
20 years on this company called blue
origin
finally flew people on new shepard
so new shepherd is a sub orbital class
rocket
similar flight profile than what we just
saw with virgin galactic spaceship two
where it pretty much just goes straight
up and that instead of an aircraft
that's just taken off from the ground
goes into a parabolic arc that gets
above the karman line releases its
capsule the first stage cleverly comes
back to earth and lands on its tail at
its launch site and then it free falls
for a few minutes and ultimately opens
parachutes and lands on the ground and
you may have seen william shatner take a
ride on it these are again
somewhat restricted products right they
can get above get into free fall for a
few minutes and there's some
experimentation you can do there
mostly it's a it's a ride for people who
have more money and need something new
to do
and then we'll throw the next
billionaire in the equation good old
elon
now
has significantly affected
the rocket industry
irrespective of the craziness you hear
in all the other things there's lots you
can complain about and billionaires are
not a lot like you and me there's no two
ways about that that's absolutely true
but what he's built in spacex with his
falcon rocket is profound he has an
orbital class rocket where the first
stage is routinely recoverable and
reused he has a number of first stage
boosters that have flown eight nine ten
times into
their flight profiles which is again
you're talking about something that's 60
meters high
that runs for two and a half minutes at
full bore
and then spends about six minutes
getting back and landing on his tail and
then you do it again you know that's
rocketry for you and his upper stage is
a conventional upper stage and this is
the this is the rocket that has been
carrying supplies to the space station
for over a decade now and recently has
begun
flying uh
station astronauts to the space station
with the crude dragon
restoring the united states ability to
fly humans into space since the space
shuttle has been retired since 2011
which by the way was the reason the geek
out started
the first geek out was me yelling at
carl about how stupid the shay shuttle
was in 2011 when atlantis was landing
and after i wound down
which took like 25 minutes and carl said
are you done
he said we should have recorded that i
don't think a lot of people know what's
wrong with the space shuttle and i'm
like why would you record that who would
listen to it he goes everybody else
they'll love it it's like i think you're
wrong i mean
we recorded it people loved it and then
we've been making gigas ever since
it's easy for folks who are not into
rocketry to conflate
spaceship two
new shepard and falcon 9. they've all
kind of developed the same time they
have somewhat similar traits uh i use
this graph and just trying to give you a
comparison
falcon 9 teeny bit bigger because it
does a very hard thing
getting up 100 kilometers not that tough
adding 25 000 kilometers per hour of
speed so that you don't fall back to
earth you just keep falling and missing
that's the hard part
and that's why this rocket is as large
as it is it's a 3.7 meter in diameter
rocket that's about 70 meters high
and
pretty much that entire rocket is
does its job in eight minutes
to accelerate a payload up to roughly 20
metric tons maximum to a low earth orbit
and
it has now been used as a tourism
vehicle this summer
four people
took a tour
on in orbit for the first time ever
straight tourists now admittedly one of
those tourists the guy who instigated
the thing
billionaire i don't know if you notice
the pattern here
so that for the person on your
left
jeric
jared isaacman uh created a company
called shift4 made a lot of money off of
it and he's a bit of an adventurer
but he's got the currently holds the
world record for the fastest light jet
flight around the earth that kind of
thing and he always does it in
conjunction with some charity work does
his best to to you know try and do some
good with his indulgences as a
billionaire
uh there are worse problems in this
world and so his charity of choice for
this particular fight flight called
inspiration for was saint jude's
children's hospital which is in the
northeast of the united states
and he donated 100 million dollars to
saint jude's he probably spent about a
hundred million on this flight and he
raised another 100 million
with the
the events around this so people making
donations and so forth got a ticket for
a chance to fly now only one of the
seats went to
the the raffle
uh the lady two hit right beside him cm
proctor is the closest thing they had to
a professional astronaut she was
actually made it most away through nasa
astronaut selection before she was down
selected she's a science communicator
she's wildly intelligent really fun to
listen to the best stories that will
come from this flight will come from
cien i expect
we're still hearing bits and pieces
there's the stuff coming out the
smallest person the bunch there haley
arsenau
is a young woman who
had bone cancer as a child and was
treated at saint jude's and has gone on
to have a career as a physician's
assistant at saint jude's so having been
a cancer survivor she now helps cancer
patients
she should fly into space and she's
really a lot of fun too right smart
capable and has medical training
all these rapidly relatively qualified
right jared flies high performance jets
has us a collection of military jets you
know as you do as a billionaire
uh sienne very nearly an astronaut and
haley you know doc a medical experience
and a lovely person and then there's
chris
chris did not win the raffle
somebody else who's chosen to remain
nameless won the raffle and gave the guy
the ticket
which is cool
now chris is a very much a space
enthusiast and he's helped run space
camps and all this sort of thing and
he's the nicest guy but believe me he is
us
if you actually want to know what it'd
be like to be a tourist in space you
should watch the videos of chris getting
ready to go into space it involves a lot
of barf bags
it's not easy to go into space people
train for a long time for this and so i
think the guy's great i think he had a
tough time
but they had this extraordinary
experience they took in a modified crew
dragon into space they had taken the
the docking adapter off of the ship and
replaced it with this plexiglass dome so
they had this sort of unprecedented view
in orbit and so we've seen a few photos
from it the this picture is of course a
see a graphic simulation it's not real
this picture is real
so when i originally was putting
together this deck was when they had
just gone up so this is actually a
camera whenever you see a picture from
something space the first question is
like where's the camera who took this
picture so they mounted a camera on the
cover
that protected this dome it pops up so
they could use a dome and it goes back
down for re-entry because domes don't
like being re-entered on and so they put
a camera at the hinge point so this is a
shot of the dome so they could take
pictures of themselves looking through
the dome
you know at the world
so if you've got 100 million dollars
burning your hole in your pocket and a
few friends this is an option now some
stories are coming out
of some of the things that went on you
have to understand
the difference between astronauts and
people
one of the things is you're in a room
not a lot bigger than the back of a
minivan
that's all the space you got
you're going to be in there for a few
days
and you got to go to the bathroom too
when you got to get changed you got to
do all the things so
the toilet actually was mounted up close
to that dome
and there was a somewhat of a privacy
curtain around it
but as they discovered because for the
most part the astronauts that are going
to and from the space station are only
in the vehicle for less than 24 hours
and astronauts tend to hold it
and so they hadn't really discovered
that the toilet leaks
you got to understand the perspective of
leakage in free fall the water just sort
of hangs
out and it's hard to manage and if you
sti if you touch it it will stick to you
so
we're not going to see a lot of what
happened inside of that cabin i bet over
the years there will be some lovely
photos of the views and so forth and
they will tell great stories
but something tells me it was pretty
challenging they were only up there for
about four days
but still i think an important moment in
history that we have actually had a
tourist flight
into orbit it's the beginning of the
idea that maybe we could have a low
earth orbit hotel that you would take
one of these vehicles up to still
extraordinary expensive the toys of
billionaires but
beats the snot out of four minutes of
free fall then you're back and you know
unless you had lunch planned
all right so that's spacex and some of
the technologies they've worked on i'll
talk about some others because i know
there's ones you want to hear about i do
want to talk a little bit about new
glenn
so new glenn is blue origins nominally
important rocket uh
because we haven't really seen it yet it
hasn't flown yet there's lots of rockets
that are talked about and have lovely
documentation because they aren't real
there is a structural prototype of new
glenn now at the kennedy space center
that they have driven around on the
roads nominally to make sure they could
drive it around the roads it is a very
large rocket
the saturn v which one of the biggest
rockets ever made whose bottom stage the
first stage was nine meters across
is bigger but it was assembled
vertically in the vertical assembly
building clever name and then
transported vertically
most rockets today including the falcon
9 and the new glenn are assembled
horizontally and then transported the
pad and stood up and so one of the tests
that's been recently done for new glenn
or the mock-up at least was can we
actually physically move around the
kennedy space center with something this
large and have a shot that we'd be able
to get it to the pad stand it up and do
its thing which is good good to test
that like to see it fly please been a
lot of years and a seven meter class
rocket is important
that is a lot more lift the falcon 9
which
it's hard to perceive of just how
successful the falcon 9 is
pretty much any payload flying into
space today that has a choice of rockets
will fly on the falcon 9 because it's
that inexpensive
but it only carries so much payload and
it can only be tuned so much farther it
is an extremely tall rocket for its size
at 70 meters it's almost too tall for
being three and a half meters wide a
seven meter wide rocket represents a lot
more power a lot more potential
performance
this should be able to lift a tremendous
amount in excess of 50 metric tons
if it exists
and i hope it does i really do
the united launch alliance which is the
american group that's been flying the
atlas v and the delta iv for the longest
time have a new rocket called the vulcan
that has been under development for some
time they say it's basically ready to go
uh and it will be the replacement rocket
it's
for the elvs the atlas 5 and the delta
iv so this is primarily american
government and military
lift that's what they will mostly do
with it
uh well it has something in common with
the glue glen besides never actually
been flown they're both depending on the
same engine an engine called the be4
that main booster engine is being built
by blue origin and is a methane liquid
oxygen engine
very very high performance engine
if it works
it seems to be the pacing item both for
the vulcan
and blue origin
uh the new glenn
nasa is still working on their own
rocket a rocket called the space launch
system
it's derived from shuttle parts that's
why it kind of looks shuttly right the
big orange hydrogen oxygen tanks the
same way that the shuttle ran on it
and the same kind of solid rocket
boosters for many years nasa did not
want this rocket congress wanted this
rocket
right in the end it's the american
congress that assigns money to nasa and
also can ear market for certain tasks
and there are con there there are
politicians that want to keep the
various people in the various states
employed
and the companies behind the space
shuttle in boeing and and lockheed
martin so forth they had spread their
work around to as many states as
possible so there's a lot of energy to
continue this going this is an
extraordinarily powerful rocket this
should be a hundred metric ton lift
rocket if and when it ever flies
fundamentally
it could have flown in the 1990s and if
it had be wicked cool
in 2023 or 2022 they might be able to
actually get one off the ground so
there's a mission called exploratory
mission one
where he's going to fly an orion capsule
around the moon with nobody in it
and then it'll be two or three years
before the try again hopefully with
folks in it
which may
spell the doom for this rocket because
they're starship
and if you've been paying attention to
space you've been watching what's been
going on with starship starship
is the craziest thing that any rocket
people have ever talked about this is
elon's folly
it might work we just don't know okay
it's enormous it's hard to understand
how big it is this is a nine meter
rocket so it's wide it's tall they have
stacked it on its booster a couple of
times just to understand it that stack
is taller than this than than saturn 5.
it's absolutely massive it depends on a
new engine called the raptor engine but
it's a hundred percent if it works and
100 reusable spacecraft
so the flight profile is that a titanic
booster with 30 engines on it will
produce the largest noise and most
amount of thrust ever achieved by any
rocket ever
hopefully
for about two and a half minutes to
shove that massive upper stage
into a position to achieve orbit
now that's not that different from a
falcon 9 then the lower stage then turns
around and goes back and lands which i
mean i want to see that's awesome but we
have seen smaller versions of that the
upper stand stage then capable of going
to orbit completing a mission
re-entering
and landing on its tail
so that the whole rocket is reused
nothing is thrown away refuel it do a
little maintenance fly it again
to optimize weight because landing legs
weigh a lot they're not going to put any
landing legs on it instead they're going
to catch it in flight because that's not
crazy
but that's elon's plan is and this thing
exists okay he has now built a tower in
boca chica with a pair of arms they call
it chopsticks
and supposedly at some point
they will have a booster come down on
its tail and come close enough to that
tower without contenting it that those
arms will be able to grab that booster
and put it down
all right
and same for the upper stage the upper
stage actually has a heat shield on it
because it is going to be going fast
enough to go into orbit and it has to
shed all that speed
and so the heat shield absorbs the heat
of it decelerating
and then it falls
and then at the last moment pivots up
fires its engines and lands on its tail
and they're arguing chopsticks are going
to catch it too
and elon's mission is to try and get
humans to mars and so he thinks this is
the vehicle capable of doing it
we could talk about that that is a
different subject this is a spacecraft
that could lift 100 metric tons
similar to the saturn 5 or the sls at
full bore except it's 100 reusable and
now we finally have to show some numbers
saturn 5 can lift about 140 metric tons
all up and for a relatively good price
per kilogram about 5 400 u.s dollars
that's adjusted from the 1970 prices to
today
and this feels fairly accurate because
below it is the space shuttle
especially a little expensive it was
supposed to be the cheap way into space
can be really efficient reusable now
that number that 65 000 a kilo
includes all the development costs the
manufacturing of all the different space
shuttles all up they did 135 missions
total lost two vehicles of 14 astronauts
but in the end that's how much money
they spent
did not deliver on its goal that's why i
was complaining about it in 2011.
uh dan golden as he was retiring as the
nasa administrator
said if we had not built shuttle and
continued with apollo we would have
flown six apollo missions a year doing
various different science experiments
including two to the moon every year the
whole time for less than what we spent
on shuttle
the americans wrote reached too far they
were trying to build a vehicle that was
too complex they did not spend enough
money developing it it wasn't good
enough
uh
i didn't include on here traditional
rockets like the atlas v or even ariane
they typically come in the into the in
the 10 to 15 000 a kilogram range for
flight which is why we get back to
falcon 9 at 2600 per kilo is why it's
consumed the entire market
it's the cheapest lift to orbit and so
it's all-encompassing falcon heavy which
is actually three falcon 9 strapped
together
because that's not crazy either
but actually can lift better part of 50
tons into orbit it's just it's got its
own problems is even cheaper than that
new glenn now now we're talking about
rockets that do never flown right aren't
real so all these numbers are lies
but the current estimates are that new
glenn will be cheaper of course it is
because there's no real battle going on
between bezos and musk but he says 1900
a kilo
vulcan at 7 500 a kilo is
extraordinarily cheap for anything made
by united launch alliance i don't know
that i believe it either
um space launch system at a 95 metric
tons of 50 000 kilo boy that's
optimistic too
with that crazy vehicle i showed you
starship where it's 100 reusable you
throw nothing away
you get down to about 150 a kilo some
numbers i've seen it's like 75 a kilo
again it doesn't work
they're working on it maybe it'll work
but if it does work and it's fully
reusable well now you're talking about
the price for you and i to go into orbit
is the price of a first class ticket to
you know across an ocean
it's fifteen twenty thousand dollars
right it's a problem it's a trip of a
lifetime
not a trip of a billionaire
and that's interesting
so
these are the vehicles that have been
worked on for now and we are going to
see results from the next few years i
don't expect all of them to come into
existence or to last very long or to be
as good as they say they're going to be
but you can watch all of them they're
real they're happening
many of them are supposed to fly
recent news around elon and the starship
the raptor engine which is sort of the
critical point of this these high
performance engines both new glenn's or
blue origins engine the be4 and
starships engine the the raptor have
problems they're very very powerful
engines they're difficult to build and
they aren't working up to specification
even the demonstration flights where
they were testing whether starship made
sense they would fly it up to about 40
000 feet let it belly flop and then land
on his tail
they blew up about six or seven of them
great fun to watch by the way too and
they finally stuck the landing on one
but one of the things you'll notice over
and over again is they never ran the
engines at full power and they burnt up
a bunch of them
the engines have problems they haven't
solved those yet
let's talk about the space station
it's our its
first components for space station flew
in 1998 it was continuously inhabited
starting in 2000 so it's been 20 years
that we have had humans in orbit on the
international space station before that
it was mir
before that there were the salyuts the
sky labs we've had a variety of space
stations the chinese have a space
station now that is occasionally
inhabited
20 years makes the station pretty old it
was originally certified the last of
2024 they've extended that to 2026
they're hoping they get 20 30 but things
are breaking it's old
and it's hard to repair
and it's quite the cost of the repairs
or replacement parts is almost more than
what it would cost to build new stations
it has served well it has taught us a
lot about humans function in free fall
the tldr is poorly
what we've learned is that the typical
human typical human being an astronaut
which is not a typical human someone who
is extremely fit athletic and has
several phds right
uh
is that they exercise two and a half
hours a day
every day on the station to maintain
some degree of health and after six
months they have enough damage they're
gonna have trouble being able to move
around getting when they come back down
so they typically limit the trip to six
months a few folks they'll stay up to a
year to learn a bit more
there are a few things that go wrong
while you're in free fall your body was
built for gravity
so a lot of things do work peristalic
systems blood pumping breathing
digestion all that stuff works burping
doesn't work
because the food floats around your
stomach and there's actually a video of
an astral astronaut showing how you can
burp on the space station which is that
you back up against the wall and then
when you go to birth you accelerate so
all the food drops down you burp if you
get it wrong you clean it up
but more importantly the real science
problem is the cerebral spinal fluid so
you have two organs in your brain that
produce a fluid that bathes your brain
and cleans your brain and those flu
those fluids then run down your spine
where they do
exchange with your blood to remove
detritus from your spine and brain now
this is a known problem that uh
bedridden people need to be sat up
pretty much every day to help that fluid
pump around to do maintenance otherwise
it does damage
and so when you're in free fall that
fluid accumulates in your head it
doesn't go anywhere which is why you'll
notice that most astronauts look rather
puffy when they're up on the space
station for people that are very fit and
marathoners and that sort of thing big
puffy heads it's because the fluids
building up in their head so much that
it presses against the back of their
eyes and it bends their eyes so they
also all tend to wear glasses while
they're up in orbit even though they
generally have perfect eyesight regular
when they're back down by the way it
takes a year for your eyesight to come
back after you
de-orbit six months up there two things
you're going to notice your balance is a
mess your bottom of your feet hurt
because you haven't walked on them in
six months
and your eye your eyes are messed up for
a year
humans aren't well suited for free fall
that's the truth that's what we've
really learned on the space station
now nasa is looking beyond the
international space station and they've
recently put out proposals around this
idea called the commercial leo
destinations program so for the next few
years up to 2025 they're taking in
proposals with the intent to have
commercial operators of space stations
they want to get out of the space
station business they just want to use
space stations for experiments they've
set specifications what they want for
the space stations and now there's a set
of proposals to fly multiple space
stations smaller space stations that are
more dedicated although blue origin
immediately presented us with this thing
called
the uh the orbital reef
which is an enormous space station
pretty much exactly what nasa didn't ask
for
you'll notice there's a backbone running
down the middle of the station
these are the reef points these are
components that will be flown by new
glen new glen is a seven meter rocket
it's got a 6.7 meter fairing
this is these modules would be about 6.3
meters across
uh regular space station components are
4.2 meters across because they had to
fit inside of the space station that's
how most of them were lifted so these
fundamentally are bigger each one of
these you can see there's actually three
modules side-by-side connected each of
those modules fly on a new as a new
glenn payload they're 300 cubic meters
of operating space the entire
international space station has 900
cubic meters after 25 flights and a
bunch of russian flights to even put
that much space on it so this is a much
larger scale the components on either
side
are
optional specialized components
blue origin's working closely with
sierra space who had their own space
station designs based on these
inflatable modules and boeing as well is
heavily involved too
so
this is more or less like three space
stations already connected together they
doesn't actually make sense to make
stations this big one of the things they
found with the international space
station is that you end up spending a
lot of time trying to find stuff
it's just like having too big a house
you store too many things in too many
locations you don't know where anything
is and so i mean it's not a small thing
that only on the international space
station they spend a lot of their time
looking for stuff to do
their various experiments and to do
maintenance and so forth not a trivial
problem
a couple of vehicles that are attached
to this uh sierra space which is one of
the participants of the station is the
guys who've been building a thing called
dream chaser
which is the the uh aircraft looking
spaceship on the side
it's been in development for a long long
time and it's been
the polite term is deselective it has
been rejected by nasa many times they're
pretty close now to actually flying it
as a cargo upload and download for the
space station but they want to get
participating in here there's also
starliner
that's boeing's alternative to crew
dragon and if you've been following this
as software people you would recognize
the problem right you know that you know
it's like okay we spent three years work
on the app let's run it for the first
time
it comes up and goes right back down
again you're like okay that wasn't good
we'll fix it no problem then we'll get
ready to try it again nope didn't work
that time either they flew starliner
once
and it was remarkable they didn't lose
the craft it went nuts burned up all of
its reentry fuel and was basically out
of control it never made it stalking to
the space station they were able to get
it back but it was just like in
programming you get to that point where
they went and looked at the results said
wow how did we get this thing back
serious software problems and some
design problems and so they actually
said well we'll refly that mission spent
a year getting ready for it
got it to the launch pad this summer
and a bunch of the flight control
systems were frozen from corrosion and
they actually had to de-stack the thing
and they think it'd take another year to
repair it
and nasa has now taken the astronauts
that were assigned to the starliner test
and put them on crude dragon so that's
how that's going
actually the coolest thing i saw in the
orbital reef proposal was a product by a
company called genesis
called which is basically a single
person spacecraft
that runs at the normal pressures in the
space station so you imagine there's an
airlock and you go through this airlock
you close it up and you're in a little
bubble with some controls and you can
detach the space station and do your
thing like right now and there's
actually astronauts working on the space
station today
to get into one of these extra these eva
suits is a several hour process
because the pressure in the space
station is high enough that if you
actually pressurized a flexible suit
like this you'd be the michelin you'd be
like
and so they run at less than one
one-third of atmospheric pressure so
that you can actually close your hands
and pick things up and be able to move
around
now the problem is that those low
pressures you can't breathe a normal air
mixture of nitrogen oxygen so what they
do is they spend a couple of hours
breathing pure oxygen and purging the
nitrogen out of the system otherwise
when they go in that low pressure
environment the nitrogen starts to
bubble out of their blood
this is the bends if you're into diving
you know this well and so
you can't quickly get out of the
spaceship right you can't leave the
station very quickly you have to go
through this process it takes hours and
because it takes hours you do a lot of
planning you don't want to get outside
this the station go forgot tools like
that's a problem right
so
when you think about a little guy like
genesis a lot of this gets easier that
now you could just simply hop in a
vehicle pop off do your thing come back
you're not going to have hands per se
although you could build a depressurized
hand like running at one third
atmosphere it probably wouldn't be as
damaging but more likely you're just
going to be able to get to the right
location get a close look at it and use
manipulators to do your work so that's
cool
uh
lockheed martin and uh nana racks who've
nano racks has flown a lot of stuff to
the space station are offering a station
much closer to what nasa is actually
asking for small stations inflatable
components maybe 300 cubic meters total
uh robotic maintenance systems little
nano sats that would pop out and do the
base maintenance on the outside of the
ship so they could maintain it but fly a
bunch of them there's a bunch of
different kinds of experiments we want
to do microgravity experiments which
we've largely done on the international
space stations are not compatible with
artificial gravity experiments
one of the things we have not done a lot
of exploration with is actually
understanding what kind of artificial
gravity we can create by creating
rotating structures and how things will
behave in reduced gravity from rotating
structures how we manage coriolis
effects other problems around that we
just haven't done those experiments
because they're not compatible with the
one station we have
by building a few stations we should
have some more choices there
last space station offering
axiom station so this is a bunch of
folks that are former space station
techs and engineers
that have now gone to create a company
called axiom they want to build out
additional modules for the international
space station in the next couple of
years
support tourists and commercial
experiments with the goal of ultimately
building enough components to make a
freestanding
station so the point being
rather than trying to build the whole
thing at once as a standalone station
let me build component by component with
the space station as another ship until
i had only have enough components four
of them that i can now leave the space
station and be my own standalone station
they seem pretty real they've raised a
quarter billion dollars which sounds
like a lot until you're talking space
they have the first component the hab
component under manufacturing by the
same company that manufacture components
for the international space station
and they are they have booked flights to
the international space station they're
essentially tourist flights
these four folks are going to go
supposedly in january of this year or
this of 2022 to the space station
they're all billionaires in case you're
wondering
because that's what it takes to spend a
week on the space station their problem
now is the space station is so busy
there's a limited amount of docking
space available and so they may or may
not be able to flight when they want to
fly
that's my space station news so far
let's talk a little bit about the moon
and what's my rule when you see a
picture from space
who took this picture
because this is a picture of the far
side of the moon
which is clearly not the dark side
right it's just the far side the moon is
tidally locked to the earth the same
side of the moon always faces the earth
as it goes around and sometimes it's lit
and sometimes it doesn't the the earth
the moon has a 28
day day
in any given location specifically on
the equator you will have 14
earth days of light followed by 14 earth
days of darkness
uh otherwise it rotates around who took
this picture a satellite the deep space
observatory now these space climate
observatory this is actually a solar
weather satellite it's in the l1
location of the earth sun system so that
is a gravitationally stable location
about a million and a half kilometers
away from the earth towards the sun
so it's always sitting between the earth
and the sun
and somebody was smart enough to put a
telescope on it on the back side pointed
back at the earth and is it a telescope
because it's a million and a half
kilometers that's a long way
so you're you're pretty small but they
get a pretty good picture it's always a
full disc because it's literally sitting
between the earth and the sun the whole
time so normally it's measuring
coronal mass ejections and solar weather
so it gives us warning on earth that the
moo the sun's up to something weird but
every so often
the moon
whizzes through the shot
and you get a cool picture like this
now
one of the interesting realities when
you're dealing with technology working
in space is they don't have like
a sony
camera on this thing right it's a
telescope and they have
uh a cmos sensor but it's a
monochromatic cmos sensor so to take a
color photograph they actually take four
pictures
and it takes a little while to take the
picture because you're shooting it
through a telescope right so it takes
about two to three minutes to take that
all of those shots and in that time the
moon moves which is why you can see if
you look close there's a bit of a green
haze on the right side of that moon
that's because the green shot was taken
last and the moon had moved a little bit
further and so you have a bit of a smear
there
but cgi you would never allow such a
smear like that right for that that's
what a real picture looks like
all right
humans have been to the moon it was the
apollo missions was part of the cold war
how do we know
the 12 men white men that walked on the
moon 11 of them were soldiers they were
test pilots typically
one of them was not
let's see if this little pointer thing
works there we go this guy
that's jack schmidt
he's a geologist
he was originally supposed to be on
apollo 18.
there were supposed to be apollo
missions up to 20 that were planned and
they started canceling them after they
succeeded getting to the moon because
this was actually a military mission to
prove that american technology was
superior to soviet technology once
you've landed on the moon once you're
kind of just taking chances
unnecessarily so they were pretty
quickly cancelling all the missions and
when apollo 18 went away there's some
folks are pretty upset that you'd only
flown soldiers to the moon so they said
hey you know can we get this one
scientist on geologist good thing to do
there's a lot of rocks on the moon
this jack on the moon you'll notice he's
dirty because he fell down a lot he was
looking at the rocks
also jack kept flipping up his visor to
see the rocks better right they've got
this gold-coated visor over his face to
reflect the sunlight so just burn your
eyes out
and so every if you listen to all the
transcripts or the audio recordings of
the talking on the moon you keep hearing
capcom saying hey jack would you get a
sec would you close your visor please
now jack was so into looking at the
rocks that what he was doing was taking
his safety cards off his sleeve and
sticking him in the side of his visor to
block the sun so he could lift his body
to look at the rocks geologists
that's what happens when a real
scientist gets somewhere where you can
really do science that you can talk to
test pilots all day long about what you
should look for in rocks they're test
pilots and the reality is that science
is not done through eureka i found it
it's like wow that's weird what's that
that's how science is done it takes a
geologist who knows what rock should
look like to find a rock that doesn't
look like what it should like hey what's
that
and that's what jack schmidt found in
his three days on the moon he found all
of the most important rocks on the moon
geologists he knew what to look for he
proved there was volcanic activity on
the moon he found unshocked olivine
which of your geology you're like wow
that's wicked cool
everybody else is like it's a rock
but
that's what happens when we let
scientists into an environment this is
what humans were built to do we're wired
to explore
if we get a chance to put them up there
we can now there's a good reason they
canceled the apollo missions it was this
thing the lunar lawn lunar excursion
module this thing is flipping dangerous
it'll support two people more or less
for three days if anything goes wrong
with it it takes more than three days to
rescue them
that's why they always plan to leave
them behind there was no way to get them
back the machine was incredibly fragile
it had a half a dozen failure modes that
none of which were survivable
we were just
lucky
that we didn't leave any bodies behind
on the moon and that's why they stopped
they achieved their military mission
they've proven their point
and they shut it down
but time has marched on technology's
improved we can do this better we can
nasa's current proposal is to put a
space station around the moon called the
lunar gateway
why
because they know how to get to an orbit
around the moon reliably they don't have
good lunar landers and they want to do
it as an international mission much like
our existing space station so canada
signed on the european union union is
signed on australia signed on okay
japanese are signed on but they all want
to build parts of it and the reason they
do it that way is because it's very hard
to cancel something that's an
international agreement you may have
noticed that every time nasa talks about
doing something a new administration
comes in and that thing goes away
but the international ones don't and
that's that's why they've been pushing
on doing this now one of the problems
you got with the moon is it's tricky to
put on to put a space station in good
orbit you're going to think like science
fiction is going to go around the moon
that way it's not what they're going to
do
they're going to put it into what's
called a near rectilinear halo orbit and
i have an animation
and this comes from
nasa johnson the lady by the name of
diane davis did this animation
so what you're looking at is how the
space station would orbit the moon so
roughly a one week period from point to
point but what it does is it passes
close by the south pole of the moon and
then it shoots way far out then it comes
back down again over and over and over
that's the near halo rectilinear orbit
and they do it that way for a few
reasons
one is it's a very stable orbit takes
very little energy to maintain that
orbit once you're in it so you don't
have to keep using fuel to keep the ship
to keep the space station stable
the second is it's always in view of the
earth
so you always have communications and
it's always in view of the sun so you
always have power you know one of the
problems we have on the international
space station in its low earth orbit is
it has 45 minutes of sun and 45 minutes
of darkness
try this with your ups
unplug it for 45 minutes
plug it back in for 45 minutes
unplug it for 45 minutes see how long
your computer lasts but that's what the
space station does continuously
charges for 45 minutes continuing to
operate all of the experiments then it
goes into darkness and it switches over
to batteries and continues experiments
on batteries and then the light comes
back on and it goes again so one of the
ways to simplify gateway is by
positioning in that orbit that allows it
to almost always have power a little bit
of battery but not that constant
45-minute cycle that eats up hardware
there's a few different hardware
proposals this is the lockmart proposal
one of the most interesting in this
picture is the center capsule there
this part
is actually resupply by a falcon heavy
it's a thing called the dragon xl an
extra large module will be lifted by
falcon heavy that could fly supplies all
the way to the gateway station so the
idea is to build a space station that's
man tended
that it normally operates on its own it
can maintain its own station keeping and
you put supplies into it and eventually
fly a group of humans out to it and they
spend
a couple of months doing their job
up close to this to to the to the moon
and ultimately to land on it and that
gets us to the lunar lander problem and
so a year and a half or two years ago
now roughly just before the pandemic
started there was a proposal
that three different companies responded
to to build a lunar lander a modern one
the first one was from the small company
called dynetix
and it was a self-contained lunar lander
it was mostly reusable there was a
couple of fuel tanks on the outside that
it would drop on the way down
and but it was capable of supporting two
people for 42 days which was part of the
requirement on the moon cool except when
nasa actually reviewed the study they
figured out that it had negative mass
which is to say it was too heavy to fly
that's the polite version of it so
move on from that one then there was the
national team the national team this was
blue origin lockheed martin boeing
working together
building a
a uh a lunar module which has the fewest
reusable parts possible this is the
entire assembly so from one from left to
right you have the boost stage that
actually flies you to the moon gets you
into orbit and gets you deorbited and
the center is the ascent stage that's
what you'll use that's the descent stage
that's what you'll land on and then
right at the top is the sn stage which
is what will get you back off the moon
and back to the space station
so it ends up being very tall you're
going to need a long ladder to get up
and down from it and you leave pieces
behind you leave pieces all over the
place you you drop that that return
stage as you as you deorbit you leave
the descent stage behind
actually one of the most important
things in this picture is the idea that
that astronaut is kneeling
because that's something that the apollo
astronauts could not do their suits were
too high or pressure and you couldn't
bend your knees that far that's why you
saw them walk like the michelin men they
really couldn't bend their knees any
more than that so building a suit that
will allow you to move around um can
make a huge difference in what they can
do up there
but it's very hard to build a base on
the moon if every time you come to the
moon you leave a part of your ship
behind
so master rejected this plan as well and
they've gone with the only one that was
fully reusable which is a modified
version
of spacex's starship
so what elon proposed is like hey we're
already building starship why don't we
build you one for the moon a few
differences uh landing legs because
you're going to need those and you can
see this little ring in the on the black
part just above the lower white part
here a little ring of holes those are
landing engines so one of the problems
you have a vehicle this big with big
engines at the bottom is you go to land
on the moon you're going to blow a big
crater underneath you with your landing
engines
and in fact you're going to put enough
force in those rocks you may send them
into orbit or maybe just suborbital
enough that it will go around the moon
and come back and hit you
like you just like the cartoons used to
except we might actually do that so
let's not do that and that's why elon
came with this idea of what do we put
the engines a good 20 meters up in a
ring so they don't put enough force onto
the ground to actually move rocks around
make it a little safer for landing you
are still 40 meters in the air so you're
going to need an elevator to get down so
it's not the perfect design what it was
was large had excess capacity could fill
all the goals and was 100 reusable
i don't know if this is actually going
to fly or not but it's certainly the
current favorited option this is the
point at which jeff bezos got really
grumpy and started suing nasa because if
you want to convince your customer to
work with you suing them seems to be the
way
uh that's what he did
now one of the problems that we've got
on the moon is the moon is irregular its
gravity varies by several percentage
points
if you ever uh listen to the apollo 11
landing cycle the original landing on
the moon
they actually separated from
eagle separated from colombia on the far
side of the moon there's half an orbit
to actually go into the landing they
wanted to land on the light side of the
moon
that was facing earth so they had radio
communications
and they had mapped the exact point of
where they would separate and what the
land would look like as they were moving
around it that's how they were engaging
in navigation and within a few minutes
of separation
neil says we're long which is
test pilot speak for something's
terribly wrong
they were several minutes faster and
this is why
when they actually came in for the
landing they were not landing in the
location that was flat and safe they
were landing in an area of house-sized
boulders that were going to kill them
all and why neil did his test pilot
thing lit up the engines and flew it by
hand across the surface and found a spot
to land safely with him 10 seconds of
fuel left
you thought it was a movie and he
actually did it
the irregular gravity is what caused the
problem made the vehicle accelerate more
than expected now one of the things
that's happened since the 1960s and 70s
when we did all this crazy stuff and now
is that we have done a detailed
gravitational map of the moon with a
mission called grail in 2009 where we
actually put two satellites flying in
formation continuously communicating
with the earth and measured how much
they accelerated separately from each
other and it made this detailed
gravitational map of the earth the blue
spots are low gravity red spots are high
gravity the current theory is that they
are what is called mass concentrations
or
where an asteroid landed with some vigor
uh and so they actually affect the
gravity of the moon and you need this
map to be able to fly back to the same
location reliably to create safe
approaches on how to access things on
the moon so we've done this we now have
to figure out how to fly around it part
of that is being able to communicate
with it so one of the european space
agency's missions is to actually put up
an equivalent of gps and cellular
communications
for the moon it's called moonlight
and it's a constellation of a couple of
dozen satellites because the moon's a
lot smaller than the earth that will
allow us to continuously identify locate
locations and provide communications on
all the way around the moon
so this is infrastructure for the moon
and it's part of the collaboration to
make it realistic to actually build a
base on the moon this is elon's mock-up
of the graphic if you've ever seen a
picture of burning man this sort of like
the burning man looks like although when
i looked at this picture i thought space
1999 like moon bass alpha many old
enough to remember that
no that's fine if you can find a copy of
space 1999
don't watch it it is terrible
okay
my childhood memories of that show are
awesome and i made the mistake of going
back and watching the original pilot and
it was bad and you were only screwing up
your childhood memories it's like
kentucky fried chicken you remember it
as great as a child don't eat it now
it's a mistake right and so yeah don't
worry about that more realistically this
is the issa plan was to build inflatable
habitats on the surface of the moon and
have robots bury them in a meter of
regolith to protect from radiation you
know one of the reasons that the
apollo missions were kept so short is
that there's a very strong amount of
radiation hitting that hitting that moon
all of the time and so you need to be
safe and that's part of the complexity
of construction on the moon
the question is what can we do once
we're there right and part of that is
experiments in low gravity this things
we need to understand about the moon
this part about us becoming a space
faring species is actually knowing how
to use the resources in the locations we
are
there's water ice on the moon we've
proven that categorically billions of
tons of it can we figure out how to
extract it and use it can we dig through
the regolith can we make can we make
structures from it can we use it to
protect our buildings
in some ways you could argue that
if there was a divine power that wanted
humans to be a space faring species they
give us a moon
because it has all of the things you
need to learn how to go further
if we're going to fly a spacecraft to
mars which it represents about a three
year round trip but six months to get
there and you've got to hang out there
for about 18 months and then it takes
you nine months to get back
really we should build that vehicle
hanging around the moon and let it sit
there and function and make sure it can
work the whole duration before we try
flying it away where we're not three
days away from home
and we should learn how to use resources
and location and we're pretty sure that
we can't put people in microgravity that
long so we actually need to experiment
with artificial gravity here's the
question
we're going to build an artificial
gravity device so we're going to build a
big ring and rotate it just like you've
seen on the movies
do we do it in one g because if we do it
needs to be like 100 meters across and
rotating pretty fast
what if one 6g is enough one 6g could
keep you healthy for a couple of years
much easier to build a rotating
structure that's only 1 6g
how do we figure out if humans will stay
healthy at 160 for an extended period of
time
put them on the moon
the moon will let us do all that testing
it's 16 all the time you don't have to
spin anything
so there are some genuine significant
pieces of science we can do up there
that the original mission one of the
reasons i got into this whole
conversation was the european space
agency talking about the kind of science
that could be done on the moon with with
occasionally inhabited spaces
it opens the door to a lot of
possibilities for what we could do to
actually expand the horizons of humanity
i know elon wants to go to mars but elon
doesn't know what he's talking about
he's very optimistic anything that we
can do on mars we really need to do on
the moon first and pretty much
everything we do on the moon we can
ultimately carry to mars
and until we do those things going to
mars is fallacy really uh
or going to venus and that's a different
talk and in fact i'll do that talk one
of these days if you enjoyed this is
this fun for you geek out dot show will
give you a list of all of these shows
so the original moon based talk is there
i talk about alternative energies
there's a bunch of fusion shows as well
i did one on antibiotics just to figure
out if many of my biology skills were
still there did okay
as well as like fun stuff like whiskey
and barbecue but mostly space and
alternative energy
beer time thank you for coming and
talking
you